got [ __ ] on the flooding about ten
million people in the central us maybe
about to see the worst flooding in
recorded history
the biggest threat is along the Arkansas
River the National Weather Service warns
of a quote significant impact to life
and property that's their words man II
before kiss is in Fort Smith Arkansas
man well how are the levees holding up
there
well good morning the levees are holding
up for now but the Arkansas River has
been creeping into neighborhoods like
this one day by day it's been a
slow-moving disaster the fear is with
additional rain in the forecast if the
levees do not hold well this type of
flooding could be unleashed over a much
larger area what you're doing here is
really racing against the waters David
Crabtree is a farmer whose land runs
along the Arkansas River he's
volunteered to stacks and bags along the
levee to try to keep floodwaters at bay
Crabtree said he's never seen the
river's water level this high and he
worries about his crops if the levees
don't hold what is the general feeling
or that you're having right now nervous
I just be like taking your paycheck away
these earthen levees run for 26 miles
along this stretch of the Arkansas River
and though they have held during
previous floods they have never been
tested like this not only by the record
height of the water but also the
mounting pressure of days worth of
flooding we have never had this much
water pressure against these levees
before melody Daniel is with the
Arkansas Department of Emergency
Management the good news is that these
levees are built to obtain heavy heavy
floodwater so even though we don't know
how much they can handle they're holding
up right now they're doing exactly what
they're designed to do floodwaters from
the Arkansas River are already
surrounding homes and businesses in
parts of Oklahoma and Arkansas these
people are suffering they're losing
everything doors in their homes
in Fort Smith volunteers Donna and Jerry
Morgan rushed to help members of their
community they have been bringing
sandbags by the boatload to a Fort Smith
neighborhood where the water is quickly
rising toward homes they told us they
have no plans to stop they'll keep doing
it until the sand runs out or we just
can't do it anymore
people here are clearly grateful for the
help but they realize that with rain
starting again tonight there may not be
much more they can do to protect their
homes
amen well I see the waters about up to
your knees a little past your knees how
tall are you and how high could these
waters go to give us some perspective
well I'm not very tall and most people
will know that at CBS but I'm definitely
not going all the way back there because
then I would be covered by water but I
think you were also pointing out just
how we're expecting this to go over the
next several days so the river is
expected to crest tomorrow at get this
20 feet above the flood stage that has
shattered all records and we should
point out that Fort Smith has canceled
classes appart as a precaution mm-hmm
all right 20 feet above flood stage
that's scary man well thank you